salve sono karim è questo il teaser del
mio show
non so quando uscirà la prima puntata
perché ci sono ancora alcune cose da
sistemare audio rimbomba la scrivania è
imbarcata e o i calzini bucati
ho voluto fare questo lei ciò perché ho
tanta gente che guarda le mie stronzate
e voglio finire nelle tendenze di
youtube guarda con tutte ste facce buffe
nelle anteprime sembra di stare in un
reparto psichiatrico
ultimamente ho ci sono loro o i
finalisti di sanremo ciao francesca
michelini vuoi diventare la mia
fidanzata
si no o forse siccome sono un uomo
fedele alle proprie tradizioni
vi posso assicurare che lo show sarà
mediocre perché la mediocrità e la cosa
che youtube si merita ma non quella di
cui ha bisogno adesso